Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vouset activez la petite cloche !
Salut les Épicurieuses
et lesÉpicurieux.
J'espère que vous allez bien,
que vous avez passé de bonnesfêtes !
Nous sommes mercredi
et je suis très heureux
de vous retrouver
pour répondre à vos questions.
pito auriol sur Youtube :
« Dis Jamy, dans ton livre
tu dis que Thomas Pesquet repartira pour l'ISS.
C'est pour quand exactement ? »
Alors je ne suispas dans les petits papiers de la NASA
mais normalement Thomas Pesquet devrait repartir
auprintemps
2021.
J'ai entendu parler du 31 mars.
Ce sera
le deuxième séjour de Thomas Pesquet
à bord de la station spatiale internationale.
La première fois,
il s'y est rendu à bord de
la fusée Soyouz,
une fusée russe.
Cette fois,
il voyagera à bord du vaisseau
Crew Dragon qui sera emporté
par une fusée Falcon 9,
développée par la société d'Elon Musk :
SpaceX.
Évidemment,
je vais suivre cette expédition de très très près
et j'aurai sûrement l'occasionde vous en reparler.
« Dis Jamy, à quand "Ponce la nuit" avec @poncefleur ? »
Alors j'airencontré @poncefleur
lors d'une émission "Popcorn" avec Domingo
et je serais ravi de retrouver@poncefleur.
Je suis persuadé
qu'il a plein de choses à m'apprendre
et à m'expliquer surles jeux vidéos.
Donc voilà @poncefleur,
j'attends l'invitation.
Une question de Louis sur Instagram:
« Dis Jamy, pourquoi le surnom
Jamy ? »
Eh bien,
je suis désolé Louis mais
Jamy ce n'est pas un surnom.
C'est mon vrai prénom.
C'est celui
qu'ont choisi mes parents
et qui figure
sur mon état civil
etsur tous mes papiers.
Eh oui,
je m'appelle
JA
MY
Magenta sur Youtube :
« Dis Jamy,
as-tu un conseil
pour bien travailler et apprendre à l'école ?
Alors si j'ai un conseil à donner,
c'est celuid'apprendre à se concentrer.
Quand vous êtes en cours,
soyez
concentrés
sur ce que dit votreenseignant
et obligez-vous
à vous concentrer.
La deuxième chose,
Et unefois que vous avez compris,
là,
vous apprendrez beaucoup plus facilement.
C'est exactement ceque je fais
quand je prépare une émission.
Je commence
par comprendre
et après
j'apprends etvous verrez ça passe crème !
Tiens,
cette expression je l'ai apprise
il n'y a pas longtemps,
en même temps,
c'était facile à comprendre.
« Dis Jamy,
tu sais comment on appelle les gens
quicollectionnent
les plaques de bouchons de champagne ? »
Eh oui je sais !
Ceux sont les placomusophiles.
Alors,
« placo »
pour la plaque,
« muso »
pour le muselet
et « phile »
eh bien parce que quand on est
collectionneur,
on aime l'objet qu'on collectionne.
placo-muso-phile.
Lojo Gon ou Lojo Gon surYoutube :
« Dis Jamy,
combien pèse les nuages ? »
Eh bien tout dépend
de la densité de l'eau qu'il contient.
Cette eau peut se présenter soit à l'état gazeux,
liquide
ou solide.
Ensuite,
il y a la surface
occupée par le nuage.
Quelques dizaines de mètres pour un cumulus.
Plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres
pour un foyer orageux.
Ensuite,
il y a la hauteur du nuage.
Certains cumulonimbus
peuvent s'étirersur 15km de hauteur.
Bref !
Si le brouillard
pèse
quelques kilogrammes
par mètre cube,
un cumulonimbus
peut contenir entre
50 000 tonnes et 300 000 tonnes d'eau.
Les plus importants
jusqu'à800 000 tonnes d'eau.
Sympa la douche !